cette vidéo est sponsorisée par Opera
Opera GX c'est un navigateur pour tous
les
gamers restez là restez là Opera GX vous
permet d'intégrer directement vos
logiciels comme Messenger WhatsApp ou
votre compte twitch et discord pour voir
qui est en ligne et en cliquant sur la
petite manette en haut vous pouvez
accéder au coin GX et avoir une liste
des jeux gratuits disponible chaque jour
sur epic ou un calendrier des sorties de
jeux waouh regardez tous ces jeux qui
sortent sur
stadia 2 Opera GX vous donne un contrôle
St sur l'utilisation de votre RAM et de
votre CPU et grâce à contrôle GX vous
pouvez aussi contrôler directement votre
bande passante avec un limiteur de
réseau et la limité pour que rien ne
vienne altérer vos performances en jeu
et ça fait même des petits bruits quand
on ouvre et on ferme les onglets je
pouris faire ça pendant des heures euh
vous voulez pas plutôt que je parle du
blour de pub et du VPN intégré
gratuitement je suis occupé là onglet
ouvert onglet fermé onglet ouvert onglet
fermé ongl compatible avec les ex Google
Chrome connectez-vous directement à vos
logiciels de musique Spotify YouTube
musique Apple music personnaliseer votre
thème de fond et avec la fonction flow
de GX mobile vous pouvez envoyer des
fichiers de votre mobile vers votre
navigateur bureau en un seul clic coucou
c'est moi comment est-ce que j'ai pu
faire sans ça avant navigateur
entièrement gratuit utilisez le lien
sous la vidéo pour le télécharger
essayez-le sans déconner c'est vraiment
bien et maintenant retrouvons une
nouvelle histoire de papi
grenier papi papi coucou papi non les
enfants ah papi mais pourquoi tu m'as
frappé ah je me suis mis au sport à la
boxe non au yoga c'est Mame concentré
quand je vous pète la gueule papi papi
tu nous racontes une histoire
une histoire est-ce que je vous ai
raconté la fois où j'allais tabasser des
criminels sans aucune justification et
en dehors du cadre de la loi oui papi
c'est même ton préférée ah oui c'est
vrai et ben je la raconte encore c'était
à la fin des années 80 j'habitais dans
la ville de violence City la ville était
autrefois une cité joyeuse pleine de
commerce et de prostitué mais des
criminels sont arrivés et se sont
emparés des rues et maintenant regardez
ça ressemble à une poubelle pleine de
commerce et de prostitué avec mes
collègues on s'est dit qu'on allait
nettoyer tout ça mais papi tu étais
policier non j'avais été viré pour une
bêtise genre génocide aggravé encore une
connerie de truc de gauchiste là j'avais
ramené des amis à moi pour combattre le
crime il y avait Blaze elle était fun de
lambada et était spécialisé dans le
judo strike
elle avait jamais réussi à avoir sa
ceinture jaune mais ses talents
pouvaient être utiles pour nettoyer la
ville mais papi tuavais pas le droit de
faire ça si é policier mais c'est pire
non ça va et puis en plus on avait le
soutien de la mairie le maire s'appelait
Hagar il s'impliquait vraiment beaucoup
pour lutter contre la hausse de la
criminalité il hésitait pas à mettre les
mains dans le camboui la criminalité a
baissé de 4 % par contre les meurtres eu
ont augmenté de 598 % donc je suis un
peu partagé
monie alors concernant le recyclage des
e us on en est où en même temps c'était
dans son programme depuis le début
on n jamais eu les pistes cyclables on
devait aller tuer le chef du syndicat du
crime dans un immeuble au centre-ville
et aller libérer ma copine qui s'était
faite enlever et qui était la fille du
MRE et qui était mon frère papi je crois
que tu mélanges tout là comment ça je
mélange tout je je je tratton laveur là
espèce de petit escalier e merde il
fallait traverser toute la cité de
violence City pour s'y rendre et c'était
une sacré trotte et vraiment très
dangereuse à cause de ous les sauvageons
sur le chemin heureusement que le maire
savait quoi faire vous en avez assez
hein vous en avez assez de cette bande
de punk et ben on va s'en
débarrasser on fait quoi on prend le
taxi pour y aller non d'abord on doit
traverser la rue à pied après on va à la
plage après on traverse le pont vers le
parc d'attraction abandonné ensuite on
prend le bateau qui nous amène vers
l'ascenseur de 300 étages puis vers le
métro et après ouais on peut aller
tabasser le méchant sinon on prend le
vélo mais non on peut pas il y a pas de
piss cyclable attention des êtres
humains bonjour Monsieur le Maire c'est
pour vous dire j'adore ce que vous
faites et du coup papi tu as fait quoi
et j'ai appelé les flics tout de
[Musique]
suite désolé j'ai j'ai paniqué c'est
l'ambiance anxiogène c'est les médias
oui la police était très rapide pour
intervenir à cette époque oh mon dieu
mon chat est coincé dans l'arbre
[Musique]
oui bon après ça avait ses avantages et
ses inconvénients c'est sûr mamie je me
suis s le t-shirt et j'ai un concours de
Judau dans une
heure violence City était une cité
pleine d'activités la rue la plus
célèbre était quand même l'avenue
principale il y avait plein de magasins
ouverts tout le temps alors là nous
avons un diner ici un autre diner alors
là par contre oui bon ça fait faillite
mais apparemment ils ont l'intention de
faire un diner c'était la rue des diners
non c'était la rue Victor Hugo pourquoi
au moins vous saviez où manger papi bah
oui on savait où manger c'est sûr on
trouvait tout ce qu'il fallait dans les
poubelles des gigot des poulets rôtis
des pommes des hot dogs des hamburgers
des sushis mais il y avait pas que ça on
trouvait aussi de l'argent des saphires
des diamants des lingots
[Rires]
d'or l'économie s'était complètement
effondré oui oui ça on connait papi hein
dans les années 80 il y avait pas encore
des GPS mais heureusement on était
toujours guidé par la main de Dieu c'est
pas là une fois on avait essayé de
prendre notre chemin mais ça c'était mal
fini oh mon
dieu mais le maire il avait abandonné
son métier papi non non non pas du tout
Monsieur le Maire trouvait toujours un
moment pour s'occuper de ses
administrés mais qui a garé cette
voiture ici c'est
une e c'est ma voiture
[Musique]
soyez citoyens sinon la progression vers
le centrreville n'était pas facile avec
tous ces sauvages qui nous Barrai le
chemin chaque quartier avait sa Faun
locale ils étaient tous différents et
bigarés et il fallait même se farcir les
chefs de chaque quartier des clown des
samouraills avec des noms bizarres
des des des moturs des kangourous lui
c'était le pire il avait mis toute la
police dans sa poche heureusement avec
blaz on formé une équipe d'enfer on
avait une alchimie parfaite oups pardon
désolé pardon désolé ça m'a échassé
désolé au bout de quelques heure on
était enfin arrivé au métro il était
entièrement détruit et tagué il y avait
des tonneaux de bois au milieu c'était
rempli de voyou et de drogué et toutes
les vitres étaient brisées comme le rurb
papi oh non non comme même pas au moins
ça sentait pas la piste là après le
métro on a dû remonter dans la rue puis
on a pris le bateau pour franchir le
fleuve puis après le port on a pris le
camion pour traverser le pont puis après
le camion on a pris un Liverpool et puis
après bah oui c'était 17h alors je suis
allé chercher mon gosse à la garderie
après tout ce traget on était enfin
arrivé au repère du syndicat du crime il
nous restait qu'à prendre l'ascenseur
jusqu'au dernier étage pour y affronter
notre ennemi et rencontrer notre destin
ah combient reste 367 vivement
qu'on en finisse je suis blessée tiens
prends ce poulet
merci papi pourquoi vous bougez tout le
temps sur place comme ça vite pisser et
finalement nous sommes arrivés face au
patron du syndicat du crime le boss de
la pgre qui avait kidnappé ma petite
amie qui était aussi la fille du maire
vous nous auriez pas frappé un homme
handicapé et du coup tu as retrouvé ta
copine PAP ah oui mais avant ça j'ai dû
me battre contre mon frère jumeau
B Jimmy mais que fais-tu là mon frère
jumeau tout ça pour savoir qui aurait le
droit de garder la fille pour c'est bon
vous voyez quoi une tradition du
Moyen-Âge qu'on a conservé c'est
important de respecter les traditions
vous
savez égalité qu'est-ce qu'on fait
maintenant à 3 ici maintenant là par
terre j'ai jamais fait ça à
échec bon vous voyez c'est nul jeu échec
et match mais papi c'est pas une
histoire ça c'est un jeu vidéo oui en
plus tu as tout mélangé pas du tout
c'est parfaitement clair on a sauvé la
ville et le bazooka a été humire j'ai
même voté pour lui papi papi tu nous
racontes une autre histoire oh bien sûr
mais ça sera pour la prochaine fois
[Musique]